- Salut à vous, gens du Québec!
- Jean-Paul II a été le prCaCaC.
Un séjour de 11 jours, en
septeme e 1984.
Au Québec, les foules se ruent
pour le voir, et l'entendre
célébrer une messe au
Parc Jarry. d d d d d d d d d ds
s'agglutinent dans le stade
olympique.
♪ Une colombe est partie
Jean-Paul II est revenu ensuite
2 au
... pour rencontrer
les autochtones dans
les Territoires du Nord-Ouest et
à Toronto, pour les Journéesses.
(musique traditionnelle)
Après les excuses officielles
envers les peuples autochtones
François annonce qu'il voyagera
au pays.
On ignore à quel moment, mais
tout porte à croire que l'aiaia.
ALAIN PRONKIN, spécialiste
nouvelles religieuses, chercheur
- Le pape, c'est certain,
Il va y avoir des messes
publiques, c'est cininin.
C'est certain qu'il va aller à
Kamloops ou à Marieval. Il va
en être convaincu.
- Un voyage coxexexe, sous haute
surveillance.
Quelques jours avant l'arrivée
une bombe a explosé à la gare
centrasasasasant à annuler
la visite du chef de l'Église.
Sans compter l'attentateeeeeeeee
Saint-Pierre...
t t t t certain qu'il y en a
certains qui ne l'accueilleront
pas à bras ouverts.e e e e e e a
sécurité, dont les coûts sontga.
PIERRE-YVES BOURDUAS, ancien
sous-commissaire à la GRauauauax
répercussions que ça pourrait
avoir à travers le monde s'il y
sujet de la sécurité du pape.
Donc, il est cerueueueue
le Canada ne lésinera pas en ce
qui a trait à la sécurité.
éféféféfi sera de respecter
la volonté du souverain pontife,
peuples autochtones pour
aiaiaiaiais traitements
perpétrés par des membres de
l'Église catholique
- C'est parce qu'on regarde
la foule autour du pape,
évidemment, dans un contexte qui
va être chargé d'émotions.
C'est un pape qui est proche du
peuple, mais en même temps,
ça crée pour les ser
garde du corps rapprochés,
un défi de taille.
(applaudissements)
- Mais le plus grand défi de
ce voyage sera, pour le pape
François, de transformer
la souffrance vécue par
les autochtones, en terreau
fertile à la guérison.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.